When season 1 of The Witcher dropped on Netflix
back in December 2019, it was an instant smash
hit.
While there were some differences between
the series and the video games, most fans
believed it to be a faithful adaptation of
author Andrzej Sapkowski's books upon which
the CD Projekt Red games are based.
A standout for many viewers was the brilliant
casting of Superman actor Henry Cavill in
the lead role of Geralt of Rivia.
The show follows Geralt — as well as the
sorceress Yennefer of Vengerberg and the Crown
Princess Ciri — as they go through various
events at different points in time, based
heavily on Sapkowski's The Last Wish and Sword
of Destiny.
Their characters go through formative events
that shape them into the legends they are
to become until all of their stories eventually
merge.
The first season was well-received by critics
and audiences alike, and expectations are
high going into season 2 — especially after
the overwhelming season 1 finale, appropriately
titled "Much More."
While fans are eager to see the continuing
adventures of Geralt and friends, some unfortunate
news has emerged from the production.
According to sources close to The Witcher's
production, Cavill has suffered injuries that
have sidelined him for the moment — although
filming has still continued for scenes that
don't include him.
As detailed in a report first published by
The Sun and later in follow-up coverage from
Deadline, Cavill suffered a leg injury while
he was shooting something at Arborfield Studios
in London.
Reports indicate that Cavill was doing his
own stunts 20 feet into the air while wearing
a safety harness, and that's when the injury
took place.
The expectation is that Cavill will remain
sidelined for "a short period of time" while
production on The Witcher continues shooting
scenes that don't require him.
The Sun published quotes from an anonymous
source who described how the injury transpired:
"The filming has been hit because of what
happened to Henry.
He was on an assault course and injured his
leg.
He just suddenly pulled up and was clearly
in a lot of pain.
It wasn't clear if an object had hit his leg
or it was some sort of hamstring or muscle
injury.
[...] It wasn't bad enough to need an ambulance,
but it's messed up the filming schedule as
he can't walk properly.
He has to wear heavy [armor] in the scenes
and he just wouldn't be able to do it with
his leg injury."
Similar to many other productions, The Witcher
is expected to go on a hiatus for the holidays
later in December, so production would stop
soon regardless of what happened to Cavill.
With the extra time off, hopefully Cavill
has plenty of time to rest up and enter production
in 2021 feeling good and healthy.
2020 has been a rough year for residents of
the Kingdom of Cintra.
As was the case with most film and television
productions this year, The Witcher had to
halt filming as a result of the COVID-19 pandemic.
Not only did this push things back, but it
also made it so that not everyone from the
first season could come back to reprise their
roles.
Thue Rasmussen , who played Eskel on The Witcher
season 1, had to drop out of the second season
due to scheduling conflicts that came about
from the coronavirus delay.
The COVID-19 pandemic also hit particularly
close to home for The Witcher cast and crew
when actor Kristofer Hivju tested positive
for the disease back in March.
The pause in filming first began in March
and lasted until August.
Filming resumed for a little while before
halting again in November after several more
positive COVID-19 cases came about within
the production.
It's been touch and go for The Witcher for
almost an entire year now, and hopefully once
production gets back on its feet with Cavill
in the saddle again, things will go smoothly
from there on out.
Fortunately, the production is able to carry
on without Cavill for the time being, so fingers
crossed that things won't get pushed back
too much.
As of right now, The Witcher season 2 is slated
to come out sometime in 2021, but keep checking
back to Looper as more details emerge in the
coming months.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows and movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don’t miss a single one.